Speaker 1: Hey, I have what I would call a gig, a
cringe moment to play for you. This isn't like a
big thing, but it's just a complete and total
backfire. California gubernatorial Republican
nominee Brian Doll tried to make a Biden dementia
joke during his debate over the weekend with
California Democratic Governor Gavin Newsom.
Now, it's not like Gavin Newsom needs any help,
as I've said before. Newsom is excellent in
talking about the insanity of the American right,
but also in direct conversations with right
wingers. I dare you. I double dare you to watch
this clip without cringing. Look at what happens
when Brian Dole tries to do a Biden dementia
joke and it just falls humiliatingly flat.
Speaker 2: Did Joe Biden legitimately win
the 2022 election against Donald Trump?
Speaker 5: Yeah, actually, he did win the
election. But the big question is, is he does he
know that that's perhaps what I wonder sometimes.
But I want to talk about him, about he being
who? Joe Biden. What do you mean by that? Well,
I yes, I agree that he won the election, but
I wonder sometimes if he actually realizes
that he's president of the United
States. Of course he recognizes.
Speaker 3: And that's why
you're insulting the president.
Speaker 5: Of course he
understands he's president.
Speaker 3: God, what a loser.
Speaker 1: Silence. Silence. One
of the most awkward silences of the entire
debate season there. I've seen that five
times now. And I still get uncomfortable from how
awkward and how flat it falls. It is not looking
good. In case you were wondering for Brian Dole in
California, the latest polling right now has it at
new some plus 23, 23, and that is expected
to be an absolutely incredible drubbing.